in our political system follow the money
isn't just important it's sort of
crucial so here's one example if you're
supporting a candidate who says they
want to get rid of fossil fuels 100
percent and switch completely over to
renewable energy you then find out that
they get half their campaign
contributions from fossil fuel companies
immediately by following the money you
know you need to look into that a little
bit more deeply and we often talk about
the Green Party in American politics as
either a bastion of inspirational third
party participation and interference
with the destructive two-party duopoly
of Democrats and Republicans or
sometimes people see the Green Party as
a nuisance that ends up helping
Republicans by taking votes away from
the Democratic candidate now the truth
is usually more complex most Green Party
candidates are running because their
green party views are really their
sincerely held political beliefs and it
does sometimes happen that they
mathematically can be spoilers right
they might get 5,000 votes in a race
where the Republican won by 2000 votes
and then we say wait a second if 40% of
the Green Party votes had gone to the
Democrat we wouldn't have a Republican
winning a seat right now so that happens
okay we now have an example of a Green
Party candidate who was literally
working for the Republicans I'm talking
about in Montana timothy adams timothy
adams was a registered Green Party
candidate he was hoping to win the Green
Party nomination and ultimately
challenged Democratic senator Jon Tester
Adams ended up losing the Green Party
primary on June 5th by a little over 300
votes to Steve Kelly so he didn't even
win the Green Party primary but what
we've now learned is that Timothy Adams
running as a Green Party candidate was
on the payroll of the Montana Republican
Party Green Party candidate getting paid
by the Montana Republican Party and also
in charge of an anti-tax group anti-tax
isn't exactly a green party platform
pillar Adams is listed as the treasurer
for Montanans against higher
taxes which is a group that was formed
to oppose a property tax extension in
the state the Green Party of Montana was
asked about this they haven't really
commented other than to say we can't
deny people the ability to file as
candidates under the Green Party . if
you get the number of votes required to
be on the ballot
the Montana Green Party can't say well
we know that you're getting paid by this
or that group so we're gonna block you
they can't do that so question one is
this an indictment of the Green Party
itself no the answer's no the possible
spoiler effect of the Green Party is
real it has been real it continues to be
real whether or not the Green Party
candidate is on the Republican payroll
if anything this tells us we should
always think really critically and
carefully about all of the effects that
exist because of a vote that we cast but
what this does tell us is that we have
to look really carefully at who were
voting for beyond just their policy
position so aside from whether timothy
adams was on the payroll of the
republican party does it make sense that
a Green Party candidate would be part of
a right-wing anti-tax group it doesn't
really make sense and as a strategy for
the right to hurt Democrats it's
actually kind of slick because you run
through the Montana Republican Party for
example you run the Republican candidate
that's the the actual candidate the
person who you hope wins but then you
also help run a Green Party candidate
you appeal to the Republicans with the
real candidate and then you pick off
some liberals with the Green Party
candidate which just helps to get that
Republican candidate into office and if
you can swing just a couple percentage
points in some districts we are talking
about even a few hundred votes counts in
some of these state Senate and state
House of Representatives seats you can
use the Green Party to help the
Republican Party win the left could do
the same thing with libertarian
candidates right if the left were
organized in this way and they don't
seem to be they could say well let's run
the best Democrat that we can but then
let's also kind of quietly run a
Libertarian candidate to take away some
votes from Republicans I'm not saying I
like this type of politics I'm
saying it's perfectly legal and both
sides could do it but it seems really
it's Republicans who are good at this
well it's fighting dirty isn't it and
we've talked about Democrats maybe
packing the court adding DC and Puerto
Rico as states you know getting rid of
voter ID laws this sounds a little bit
more extreme but it's something
Republicans will do will continue to do
I mean it's not like it's a lot of the
realm of possibility for them it's one
of those things where there's it's like
when you have an attorney review a
contract for you and they say listen
here's a list of things that the other
party could do if we don't change the
contract and then normal people would
say okay but they're not really gonna do
those things do we need that in the
contract and a good lawyer will say I'm
not here to tell you what I think
they'll do I'm here to tell you what
they would be allowed to do there is
nothing that prevents the Montana
Republican Party from doing this period
now in this particular case it's gonna
be a non-starter because the Republican
funded Green Party candidate lost the
Green Party candidate that one I believe
has been kicked off the ballot because
he didn't actually have the number of
signatures that they needed so
ultimately it looks like it's just gonna
be John tester again which we all
probably could have predicted so in the
end it's not going to have an impact but
this is yet another strategy that you
are allowed to do that Democrats should
at least be aware of and all voters
should be skeptical of when they hear
about any candidate and rank-choice
voting would also solve this issue
because yeah if someone's super far left
they probably would vote for the Green
Party is their first option the
Democratic Party is their second option
sure then the Republican Party is the
third option yeah so given that the
Green Party candidates probably not
going to win that vote would go to the
Democrat and in that way it's not like
you're taking a vote away from the
Democrat by joining for Green Party yeah
of course that would be a much better
system than the one we have but that
that is not it doesn't look like that's
happening anytime soon that's for sure